David Cassidy in critical condition ET  can confirm the 67 year old actor was  rushed to a Florida Hospital in critical  condition on Wednesday where he is  suffering from organ failure including  his kidneys a rep for Cassidy tells ET  he is currently conscious and surrounded  by family the former child star has also  been suffering from dementia after being  diagnosed over two years ago  Cassidy rose to fame for his role as  Keith Partridge in the 1970s hit sitcom  The Partridge Family isn't she something  else she's so beautiful and made his  mark as a teen pop idol with his musical  talents creating such hit songs as  cherish and the pop sensation I think I  love you  [Music]  so employers  [Music]